[Music]
all right crystal
yes crystal where'd you grow up where
are you from originally i'm originally
from well i was born in ohio
raised in virginia and raised kind of
like
back and forth between ohio and virginia
for a minute you know
no not do you grew up with both your
parents no i grew up with my mom
and then after like i think i was about
three years old when i
got my grandma got custody of me
when i was four that's right i was four
years old my grandma got custody of me
for about
five years why did you leave your mom
and go to your grandmother um well my
mom
had abusive boyfriends i was
one years old when she threw me out of a
second story building
because dude set our bed's on fire me
and my brother
she dropped my brother down my brother
was like six years old and uh
she literally like tossed me out the
window because dude set our bed
our bed's on fire you know i mean who
set your bed on fire my mom's
ex-boyfriend his name was bob i believe
yeah
and uh yeah
that's kind of why like it's just too
much you know i mean after bob it was
mike
and mike mike beat us pretty much for
everything under the sun you know like i
remember getting my my ass
my butt whoop sorry for uh huh you can
swear
i didn't touch a bug there was like a
dead bug on the floor and i didn't pick
it up and
i got my i got my ass beat with a paddle
with holes in it
i was like six years old i think for
that but uh
like i don't know it was crazy
so a lot of physical abuse yes a lot of
physical a lot of mental too like
being called names you know told you
worthless
the whole nine you know it never got any
better
so we went moving with my grandma so no
sexual abuse
um not time to live with my grandma when
i moved in with my grandmother
i was with my grandfather he molested me
pretty much
for about the time i was three
up to about time i was seven and
like i said the sad part about that is
my mom knew my grandmother knew
and all my aunts knew because he did it
to them when they grew up
you know i mean like so i'm the only
granddaughter out of my whole family
it was it's just just me and all my boy
cousins so
they they never experienced that you
know my grandfather didn't touch them
but uh yeah i remember
he would get mad at me too like i don't
know it was crazy like he would get mad
but i go tell everybody in there they
would they wouldn't believe me you know
they already knew that happened though
so like
i just i don't understand why they let
me go through it
the way they did but there's a childhood
like that
where'd that take you as an adult
wow that's a good question though um
i actually met the father of my children
at a bar um we have three boys together
my oldest is 16 and my youngest is nine
and uh like throughout
that relationship
he was abusive he used drugs
like really bad and like hit him from me
um i think going through what i went
through
in my childhood is like it kind of
reflects on the men that i pick now
because every relationship i've been in
has been abusive
so it's like that i kind of
that that put me in a bad spot you know
like i use drugs
as a comforting mechanism
i i just can't i can't handle it when
i'm not high i just
it's overwhelming like i want to give up
though
what is your drug heroin here
i use heroin crystal smoke pot
you know and where you're living now
um i currently live on a street to
really
a skid row yes i don't i don't have a
spot
exactly because all my intents get
stolen my tents get stolen like like
clockwork you know
so i kind of gave up on having a spot i
just bounce around you know
from spot to spot go around people i
know you know
how do you support yourself now um i
panhandle i fly a sign on on the corner
i ask people for money i get rejected a
lot
like a lot i'm lucky to make 10 15 bucks
a day
but that's life you know you're not
doing what some of the other girls will
do for money
i have you know i'm not gonna lie i'm
not gonna sit here in line
i have um
but that was like only when i was really
hard at you know
i'm the type person i
i kind of treasured myself you know i
mean i did anyways like
i'd rather go out here and work my hands
dirty and make money you know what i
mean
earn it instead of like sell myself
because
that's just not in the cards for me it
don't work for me and so
i've done it once maybe twice i said i
just couldn't do it like i felt
degraded you know yeah i think i think
that it affects everyone that way
yeah so they realize it or not yeah it
just
it's not not for me like i'll go out
here and paint a house or
you know watch somebody's car
mechanically work on something you know
i've got mad talent
it just goes to waste you that
kids i do i have four three boys and a
girl
who are they um my three boys are
currently with my my ex-mother-in-law
down in florida
um they're pretty much the only family i
have
my entire family passed away last summer
last december 11 okay december 11th is
my mother's birthday
um the father of my children
yeah okay hold on my my boys okay my
my mom passed away december 9th last
year and the father of my children
passed away
december 11th then my brother killed
himself
on december 12th and then my dad down
here
my biological father he died december
17th
so um
and then like my best friend
he was the one i was in a relationship
with him after the father and my
children
he passed away on december 20th all last
year
wow so like i'm kind of
i hate to say it but i really haven't
mourned that
i haven't mourned any of them yet i've
just kept myself high
my daughter my daughter's three she's
down here
she's actually about four blocks from
here who's she staying with
uh she stayed this whole day it's over a
couple i met i met the lady online
do like a pen pal thing through my email
and i've been talking to her for
probably about
i say about six years and she told me
her life story out
she was in a car accident couldn't have
kids and her husband was looking to
adopt
well i found out i was pregnant and as
soon as i found out i told her because
you know
i live out here on the street i use
drugs you know i can't i can't get out
here
and i told her about it and you know i
got myself clean for that year
i maintained a pregnancy and she came
out
beautiful nice healthy she's an amazing
amazing little girl and i i signed her
over
to to them immediately at birth
and i i think it was probably the best
thing i could do for her
hey she she's a little angel guys she's
she's beautiful she's like uh she looks
like somebody plucked her off a store
shelf guys she's just
[ __ ] beautiful and she's she's
amazingly happy right there i could not
have made a better choice for her
as a parent
people might call me a shitty parent for
that but i don't
if i was a shitty parent i would have
done drugs and kept it kept the baby and
me living on the streets that's a shitty
parent
giving her a life dog that that's not
that's
that's a good parent to me you know
what's up what's the hardest part of
your life
being away from my kids my three
children i was with them from the time
they were born i was i was a
stay-at-home mom i love being a mom bro
my kids are everything to me
and it sucks i have no contact with them
now because of my drug use
[Music]
that hurts that is definitely definitely
the hardest part of my life
because i've been out here six years
almost seven years now
i'm stuck do you see any hope of
getting out of here getting clean i hope
so
as of right now i i can honestly say no
i can't see that in my future
only because
like i said i'm stuck uh my hair when i
and until until that drug stops
i can't can't go home you know
i mean they're they're being well taken
care of you know i'm
very grateful to my mother-in-law i i
that woman has earned so much of my
respect
like she's number one in my books bro
hands down
she's amazing she's raising three of my
children now
she's doing something that i couldn't do
i'm highly grateful to her for that you
went
you went through a lot as a child but is
there something you would
pinpoint as the main reason that you're
in this predicament today
that happened back then my mother
that's just that's that's baseline my
mom was a shitty parent
she chose men and and the bars more than
she chose me and my brother my brother
practically raised me you know
my brother is the one who told me about
women having a period you know he's one
who taught me how to use
you know kotex i mean that's that's
crazy you know i mean
i i blame my mother yes my mom's the
reason that my kids were taking from me
um all because i did not order her food
correctly over the over the phone
she took she called children's services
and
she trashed my house and told them that
i smoked pot and they drug tested me and
seen my house all dirty and they took my
kids
because of her i blame my mom for every
situation i'm in right now
now that's not cool to say but hey it's
the truth that i'm
not gonna say remind nobody you know
my mom is definitely the baseline of my
problems
definitely but like it hasn't been easy
for me out here either you know i mean
it's just as hard
like i have to fight for everything i
have like my [ __ ] gets stolen all the
time
i've been raped three times out here
i've been beat up and you name it it's
happening to me now
it's a rough neighborhood but hey i'm
still alive and kicking
i said the worst thing i got is a scar
that's
i say being a single white [ __ ] out
here in california
on the streets i i make it happen though
no matter what what do you worry about
what do i worry about like out here on
the street what's your biggest concern
my biggest concern in life period
is not making it home to my kids or
making it home and them rejecting me
for me being gone for so long i like i'm
terrified of that
is shame a big part of you extremely
like
like i'm ashamed i'm disappointed
like i'm
it's almost like a disgrace that i said
to my to my
relatives to my family that
for me to be out here
yeah i'm very ashamed to be out here
i i'm a certified genius bro i have a
certificate i
i i was in the air force they i
went to nursing school i'm ryan i'm a
certified rn i
hate yeah i'm out here on the streets
doing drugs you know
it's a [ __ ] up thing what's the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
the most important lesson i've learned
the most important lesson i've learned
is if you you know if you have a good
parent
or if you have good parents or people
who who
taught who raised you
respect them that you mean i
have that respect for the elders that
give them the appreciation that they
deserve because
not many people get that in life
and like a hard lesson a hard lesson
that i've learned is don't judge people
you don't know anybody's story that
everybody has one
everybody has a story that don't judge
anybody by your cover
you don't know what they went through in
their life you know
all right crystal thank you so much for
sharing your story no problem
i wish you the best of luck with your
kids yes sir thank you
thank you
you